son las 8 de la mañana en bajo chiquito
la policía de fronteras de panamá se
prepara para transferir a cientos de
migrantes hacia campos de cuarentena
solamente faltan personas
vienen del mundo entero tras un año de
pandemia en abrir de nuevo este estrecho
y difícil paso hacia américa del norte
77 masculino y uno femenino tenemos
desde diferentes versión a lidades
tenemos tenemos de palestina afganistán
todos tenemos todos han caminado durante
al menos cinco días a través de la selva
impenetrable el darién una inmensa
barrera vegetal que separa a colombia de
panamá ninguna carretera la atraviesa el
camino éste ha estado durísimo de lo que
venimos caminando nos roban todo
dormimos en el piso no traemos cobija y
venimos sin nada de plata nada una
odisea que fue el único recurso para
anís en la medida en que las puertas de
europa están cerradas
pérez no vida no hay vida en mi país no
hay salarios
a los doctores no les pagan yo soy
ingeniero sólo busca una vida mejor
hacía 20 años que esperaba poder salir
palestina está en auto en irlanda to go
out from gorda
pero agua número 2
la organización internacional para las
migraciones oim vigila de cerca la
situación en el darién donde cada año
varias decenas de emigrantes pierden la
vida a una señora dio a luz en la trocha
tenía el niño de cinco días de nacido
este niño venía deshidratado venía ella
deshidratada el esposo deshidratado
desde méjico identificamos en el 2019
que las personas que más accedían a los
servicios que habían de atención
psicosocial eran personas que tenían de
cierta manera algún vínculo relacionado
con su cruz o por láser baldar ya el
flujo migratorio volvió a la misma
densidad previa a la pandemia un desafío
para panamá mientras que durante cerca
de un año dos mil 500 migrantes quedaron
bloqueados en los campos instalados por
las autoridades como todas todos los
países producto de la pandemia cerraban
sus fronteras entonces nosotros teníamos
cierta cantidad de migrantes que no
pudieron seguir continuar o no pudieron
seguir con su flujo controlado y fue ahí
donde nosotros estuvimos que quedarnos
con esos migrantes por qué equis
cantidad de meses
algunos quedaron bloqueados en ciudad de
panamá tras un año de su paso por el
darién jefferson aún tiene rastros de
las picaduras de los insectos de la
selva que le provocaron fuertes fiebres
haría que el brote ya y el aumento yo
tuve tres meses encerradas en la
migración con la enfermedad ya se me
brota la enfermedad
yo angustiado desesperado
yo lloraba le pedía todos los diarios
trata de ahorrar 300 dólares para
regresar a colombia para el la amarga
aventura de la migración terminó hasta
lo que los thalys estoy buscando una una
ayuda sólo quiero volverme a mi país de
nuevo chaparrita acá no tengo la forma
cómo trabajar porque nutrición papel me
siento atrapado como atrapado el
personal de este refugio católico quedó
frente a un doloroso dilema ayudar a
cientos de migrantes bloqueados en el
país y al mismo tiempo tener que reducir
su capacidad de acogida por razones
sanitarias nos sentíamos como como hogar
luisa o como albergue con muchas más
restricciones para poder dejar ingresar
a las personas utilizan a panamá como
tránsito están siendo muy está haciendo
muy difícil la situación de poder seguir
porque en este momento costa rica aún no
abre fronteras tras un largo periplo en
piragua y en bus los migrantes salidos
del darién llegan al campo en el que
tendrán que pasar 14 días de cuarentena
yo sé que usted vienen de una trocha que
es muy difícil ya estamos a un paso lo
que necesitamos de ustedes es paciencia
atrás casi morir de agotamiento en la
selva e me está decidida a continuar su
camino la llegada de joe biden a la casa
blanca le hizo nacer la esperanza de una
vida en eeuu es una motivación porque es
un demócrata
según lo que puede ver en televisión
dijo que protegería a los migrantes no
sé si sea cierto y se fuese a ser el
próximo país en su ruta costa rica solo
abrirá sus fronteras terrestres en abril
mientras la pandemia afloja poco a poco
su influencia sobre el mundo la ruta de
los migrantes sigue siendo empinada e
incierta